de monde c'est squeeze on se retrouve
aujourd'hui samedi avec un temps
totalement pourri un froid vraiment très
important enfin en tout cas pour ceux
qui sont vers paris je sais qui en a où
il fait super beau chez eux et tant
mieux pour vous êtes vraiment des
du gouverneur moi je vous le dis
donc à l'issue de ce temps glacial je
vous qu'on peut juste un petit evan d'un
petit événement sur ma chaîne parce que
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup de gens qui
sont restés chez eux
donc c'est l'occasion de geeks et de
regarder des vidéos c'est pourquoi je
vous conte pause d'aujourd'hui
le samedi des tentes alors c'est quoi ce
samedi les donc bah c'est à compter de
le peu de cette vidéo
oui celle que tu entendes regardez là
tout de suite maintenant là où tu
m'entends dire ça et tout à vue où il y
aura quatre vidéos qui seront un peu
navette une heure et demi d'intervalle
la première c'est sur naruto elle est
déjà disponible puisque j'ai sorti en
mai tant que cette vidéo là et puis ces
dates détendre c'est à dire que voilà un
bon comme on dit des conneries on se
marche sur des jeux sur lesquels je fais
pas beaucoup de vidéos par exemple il ya
du naruto il ya du tekken fin où j'ai
déjà fait des vidéos youtube mais voilà
c'est passé par bonheur je veux dire
c'est voilà des jeux ou jouets comme ça
commente ans et puis bah comme ça ça
vous fait découvrir les jeux ça vous
fait découvrir un squeeze est un peu en
mode posé sur son jeu pas tous fous
genre pas comme ça en gros je vous
propose un samedi ou puisqu'on est
beaucoup est chez nous on se détend
devant des vidéos
donc voila vous allez voir des vidéos je
supplie son associé avec wayne rooney
les autres je suis tout seul mais voilà
ça peut être drôle amusant et puis on va
parler un peu plus des jeux aux rebelles
je vais pas te raconter ma vie dans ces
vidéos là
bref je vous laisse découvrir ça avec la
première sur naruto dans une heure et
demie il en a encore une zone dont trois
heures encore ajouté 90e encore une
autre
et puis j'espère que ça vous plaira
j'espère que ce petit est bonne je
prétends de faire des vidéos veille
enfin hier pour pouvoir vous proposer ce
petit truc sur ma chaîne un petit
événement un peu sympa j'espère que ça
vous plaira et là je me répète comme un
con et puis voilà je vous laisse aller
voir ça c'est parti cliquez là pour voir
la vidéo la photo on se retrouve tout de
suite
pis tiens un petit peu de merde avec tes
cheveux en épi tapas